c'est sans contredit une des oeuvres les
plus marquantes de sa carrière vol
au-dessus d'un nid de coucou aura permis
à milos forman de gagner son premier
oscar à titre de meilleur réalisateur en
1976 un film culte qui a donné lieu à
des scènes classiques
neuf ans plus tard il réitère avec
amadéus
long métrage tourné à prague alors
encore sous le régime communiste
ce sera la première fois que milos
forman remettra les pieds dans sa
tchécoslovaquie natal depuis son exil
aux états unis avant le printemps 68
amadeus est une fiction inspirée
librement de l'histoire de la vie de
mozart
jalousé par un compositeur envieux au
talent moyens antonio salieri
[Musique]
le film fut nommé 53 fois dans
différents festivals et remporta 40 prix
notamment huit oscars et quatre golden
globes en 1979 milos forman décide
d'adapter au grand écran la comédie
musicale à succès air présentée à
broadway depuis une dizaine d'années un
hymne pacifiste en réaction à la guerre
du vietnam qui deviendra une oeuvre
phare du mouvement hippie d'autres
grandes oeuvres vont aussi marqué le
public notamment le film biographique
sur la vie du fondateur de haussler
larry flint est aussi son film sur la
vie de l'humoriste absurde andy kaufman
mène en 2000
[Musique]
milos forman laisse derrière lui un
héritage cinématographique colossal il
aura été une figure marquante de
l'émergence culturel tchèque de la fin
des années 60 aux côtés de milan kundera
ou de vaclav havel icf couture radio
canada montréal
[Musique]